in einer neuen studie stellt der us
astronom james beckford eine spannende
these auf demnach könnte es gut möglich
sein dass uns intelligente außerirdische
seit langer zeit beobachten und zwar mit
hilfe von spezieller überwachungstechnik
die für genau diesen zweck auf so
genannten ko op zahlen objekten der erde
installiert wurden demnach hätten wir
quasi einen spion direkt vor unserer
haustür und zumindest dance band fort
ist sich sicher dass wir dort mal
genauer nach alien spuren suchen sollten
und genau das soll auch bald passieren
trip zum science und fiction hier gibt
es spannende science - abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocken nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen james beckford ist nicht nur
us astronom sondern auch wti forscher
das steht für search for
extraterrestrial intelligence also für
die suche nach extraterrestrischer
intelligenz seiner neuen theorie zufolge
ist es gut möglich dass intelligente
außerirdische schon vor langer zeit
lebens spuren auf der erde entdeckt
haben möglicherweise schon vor mehreren
hundert millionen jahren vielleicht
überwachen sie uns also schon deutlich
länger als wir menschen überhaupt
existieren benford spekuliert ob
außerirdische schon vor langer zeit
signale in richtung der erde aus
gesendet haben doch da sie wohl keine
antwort bekommen haben installierten sie
spezielle überwachungstechniken in der
nähe der erde und zwar in sicherer
entfernung auf so genannten ko orbitalen
objekten in der fachsprache werden damit
himmelskörper bezeichnet die sich genau
wie ein zweiter größerer himmelskörper
auf derselben oder einer ähnlichen
umlaufbahnen um ein zentralgestirn
befinden um lebensspuren auf der erde zu
beobachten müssten die außerirdischen
also gesteinsbrocken ausgewählt haben
die die erde begleiten teilweise auf der
gleichen umlaufbahn wie die erde um die
sonne ein beispiel für solch ein
kapitales objekt ist der us tour 2010 tk
hierbei handelt es sich um den ersten
entdeckten trojaner der die erde auf
ihrer umlaufbahn begleitet aber auch der
astro in 2016 03 kommt in frage
der kleine brocken wurde im frühjahr
2016 entdeckt und seine umlaufbahn um
die sonne ist wirklich sehr speziell
denn er kreist in einem jahr einmal um
die sonne und zwar auf einer
elliptische banken sowie die erde eben
auch so 2016 hahn und rain ii wirklich
weit von uns entfernt manchmal wird er
deswegen auch als unser zeitweiliger
quasi mond bezeichnet bisher wurden
weniger als 20 solcher objekte entdeckt
doch genau diese könnten sich ben folds
theorie zufolge perfekt dazu eignen das
leben auf der erde zu beobachten dazu
schreibt er in seiner studie
diese erdnahe objekte bieten eine ideale
möglichkeit um unsere welt von einem
sicheren natürlichen objekt aus zu
beobachten
deswegen ist der us astronom auch
überzeugt davon dass wir dort mal
genauer suchen sollten selbst wenn wir
nicht direkt auf alien technik stoßen
könne man nicht ausschließen dass wir
zumindest spuren des außerirdischen
lebens aufspüren können andere fachleute
sind da eher zurückhaltend unter anderem
weil der einsatz von optischen oder
radioteleskopen für diesen zweck nicht
besonders erfolgsversprechend ist dazu
der us astrobiologe paul davies wenn es
nicht besonders viel kostet dort
nachzusehen warum nicht selbst wenn wir
dort nicht die entdecken finden wir
vielleicht doch etwas interessantes doch
um wirklich auf kapitalen objekten nach
spuren zu suchen ist wohl der einsatz
von raumsonden notwendig china hat in
diesem frühling 2009 10 angekündigt den
asteroiden 2016 h 0 3 besuchen zu wollen
und dort proben zu sammeln die mission
soll im jahr 2022 staaten und zehn jahre
dauern bei dieser gelegenheit könnte
herauskommen
ob dieser erdbegleiter tatsächlich als
außerirdischer wachposten genutzt wird
welche sprache sprechen aliens hier
anklicken anschauen und unbedingt
neugier zone abonnieren das ist unser
shooting star im wissenschafts netzwerk
essent 1054 klasse kanal also bis dann
bleib dran